22h15 votre soirée spéciale municipal en
bourgogne se poursuit sur france 3 avec
de nouveaux invités à nos côtés gilles
platret bonsoir bonsoir votre liste
d'union de la droite a été élu la
semaine dernière au premier tour à
chalon sur saône avec nous également
josé almeida bonsoir bonsoir nouveau
maire socialiste de longvic et lui vaut
aussi au premier tour la semaine
dernière vous avez pris la succession de
claude darciaux des résultats ce soir
avant tout avec vous elle a besoin
on rappelle les principaux événements
pour la nièvre d'abord oui et ce coup de
théâtre à nevers vous en a parlé tout à
l'heure de ni thurios on part de ce fief
socialiste ancienne ville de pierre
bérégovoy il remporte la mairie avec
49,8 % des suffrages
varennes vauzelles toujours dans la
nièvre le parti communiste perd cette
ville isabelle bonicel divers droite est
élu avec 42 7% des voix
clamecy claudine claudine pardonnez-moi
boisorieux divers gauche est réélu avec
une voix d'avancé devant le socialiste
michel car voyeur viol d'un prénom
oui guy férez garde la tête de sa ville
natale le socialiste l'emportent de plus
300 voix face au jeune député ump
guillaume larrivé as ans marie louise
fort serait installé dans son fauteuil
de maire la candidate ump udf totalise
plus de 51% des suffrages dans l'yonne
toujours la ville de tonnerre bascule à
droite dominique aguilar divers droite
s'impose face au socialiste pascal
lenoir dauphin d'andré fourcade
on continue avec l'assemblée loire je
vais enchaîner il briguait un quatrième
mandat il est sèchement battu à montceau
les mines le socialiste didier mathus
c'est marie claude jarrot ump qui
remporte la mairie avec 50% des
suffrages réélection au creusot d'andré
billardon socialiste il gagne le scrutin
face au divers droite charles landre
cluny la gauche perd cette ville c'est
le sortant jean luc delpech qui est
battu par henri bonnyaud le candidat
divers droite qui réalise 40 84% et des
suffrages on termine avec tournus où le
maire sortant jean legros divers
gauche perd son siège c'est claude roche
ump udi qui remporte le scrutin
et pour être tout à fait complet la côte
d'or voilà on termine avec la côte d'or
à talant gilbert menut ump est réélu
haut la main il recueille 45% des
suffrages
suite au coude à coude le divers droite
cyrille gaucher et le ps stéphane
wojnarowski à chenôve réélection on en a
parlé tout à l'heure de jean esmonin il
conserve son siège avec 41,2 % des
suffrages c'est deux points de plus que
son ancien adjoint ledit site en
enrôlant onssa à semur-en-auxois
changement mère victoire de la candidate
centriste catherine sadon qui emporte la
mairie avait que 56% des suffrages face
au sortant le divers droite philippe
aiguillon 43% à dijon c'est donc
confirmé françois rebsamen entame un
troisième mandat à la tête de la ville
il est réélu avec 52 8% des suffrages
devant alain houpert 34% à edouard
qu'avant 13%
merci elsa et justement nous évoquerons
la situation de dijon dans un instant
puisque alain houpert nous a rejoint
bonsoir vous étiez le candidat de la
droite de l'ump et de l'udi sur la ville
de dijon
avant cela je vous ai vu griffonné
frénétiquement alignant à eric analyse
non pour résumer un peu ce que tout ce
que vient d'écrire elsa il ya deux
villes qui doivent interpeller qui
résume à peu près la situation ces nos
verres et montceau dans ces deux villes
les maires sortants étaient en
difficulté mais dans ces deux villes on
sait qu'il y avait des appareils de
gauche extrêmement important une culture
locale et on pouvait penser en tout cas
se poser la question de savoir si
l'appareil militant il allait être
suffisant pour ramener des électeurs
pour motiver les gens dans les deux cas
très clairement ça n'a pas été suffisant
puisque on l'a dit didier mathus et
battu etc à nevers florent sainte fare
garnot dans une ville où le parti
socialiste est extrêmement puissant il
l'a pas emporté non plus donc ces deux
villes peuvent tout de même pour cette
soirée parce qu'il ya eu d'autres
symboles et chalon sera peut-être un
puisque gilles platret sur notre bateau
mais ces deux villes elles peuvent
résumer ce qui s'est passé ce soir avec
peut-être un complément pour la côte
d'or dont on voulait parler oui juste un
petit focus sur semur-en-auxois puisque
la semaine dernière trois candidats
étaient en mesure de se maintenir il ya
également notamment michel neugnot et
michel deniau c'est le premier
secrétaire fédéral du parti socialiste
qui s'est finalement désisté au profit
donc de catherine sadon qui a été élu ce
soir donc ça a fonctionné voulais
absolument faire barrage à philippe
guyenot donc le maire sortant qui avait
fait une campagne bison avec un discours
très à droite et donc finalement cet
appel à voter pour catherine sadon a
fonctionné on parler de soi dans sur
saône de jeu les plâtres et les lions en
braille tout de suite à avec la
situation on sent les douars donc tout
de suite fictivement gilles platret vous
êtes avec nous ce soir c'était 1983
vague bleue dominique perben prend la
ville de chalon sur saône à la gauche
2014 est ce que vous considérez que
chalon est un symbole c'est un symbole
d'une campagne de terrain je pense
d'ailleurs qui a des similitudes avec 83
j'avais 10 ans à l'époque se référer à
des souvenirs personnels mais c'est une
campagne de terrain qui qui s'est fondée
absolument pas sur des enjeux nationaux
on avait l'occasion d'en discuter lors
du débat vous aviez organisé sur place
mais sur des enjeux locaux qui tenait la
circulation aux impôts est également à
l'emploi qui va mal sur le secteur donc
on a mené cette campagne on l'a mené
dans l'union c'était important aussi de
le dire c'était un élément moteur dans
cette victoire je pense et c'est un
discours et des thématiques qui se sont
imposés tout au long de la campagne
depuis le mois de novembre ont fait
depuis qu'on a commencé et en même temps
que sirugue il est vice président de
l'assemblée nationale
très marquée politiquement est ce que ça
joue un rôle moi je pense qu'il ya eu
effectivement des considérations
nationales c1 ça me paraît imparable
d'un autre côté on a vraiment fait
campagne sur des enjeux locaux et comme
on a entrepris une grande campagne de
consultation parce que ça s'est fait
vraiment près du terrain au porte à
porte 24000 port des réunions de
quartier 26 donc on a on n'a jamais
entendu une aspiration à voir les thèmes
nationaux prendre le pas sur les débats
locaux donc c'est pour ça que je dis oui
bien sûr il ya un phénomène national qui
d'ailleurs s'amplifie à l'échelle de la
france tout entière
ce soir on le voit bien mais pour chalon
sur saône il y avait je pense majorité
une grande majorité de thématiques
locales qui sont imposés dans le débat
peut-être une question à jeu
et almeida qui est également un nouveau
maire mais vous c'est un petit peu dans
un cas différent puisque vous êtes une
succession les successions c'est
toujours un peu délicat surtout quand il
ya un contexte national défavorable
alors qu'est ce que vous avez fait pour
finalement être un survivant de la
gauche ce soit je suis pas un survivant
de la go pour même si l'on vit est
classé à gauche
oui oui j'entends bien je m'entends bien
votre votre marque moi je me permet
d'abord de commencer en lançant en
adressant un message républicain de
félicitations à l'ensemble des maires
qui vont prendre leurs fonctions dans
quelques jours les maires de la
bourgogne c'est vrai dont je suis
maintenant c'est vrai aussi que les
résultats sont décevants sont mauvais
sont très mauvais pour la gauche donc au
plan national
je crois que il faut entendre le message
des français au niveau national mais il
est vrai aussi que j'ai été élu dès le
premier tour à longvic c'est la ville
industrielle de la côte d'or et j'en
suis très fier c'est vrai que cette
campagne a été très très particulière
pour moi parce que c'était une campagne
de transition donc il fallait réussir
et puis dans un contexte très
défavorable pour pour le pays aussi donc
nous avons fait une campagne de
proximité
en fait je crois que l'atout essentiel
la clé pour comprendre ce sont ces
élections locales finalement pour pas je
pense tout mélanger sommes bien dans des
élections locales où il ya des enjeux
d'abord locaux avec une histoire local
que les habitants prennent en compte ou
pas dans ce cas précis nous avons fait
une campagne de terrain avec une
approche
très de proximité oui avec des porte à
porte des réunions de quartier c'est
vrai que nous avons commencé très tôt
très tôt
malgré que nous étions sortant et j'ai
fait mien le bilan de claude darciaux
que je remercie que je salue ce soir et
je remercie aussi l'ensemble des
longviciens pour la confiance qu'ils
font qui me font en fait voilà janssen
mesdames merci on va évoquer l'ump avec
alain suguenot le maire de beaune
responsables de l'ump en côte d'or une
sucrée mais tout à l'heure on écoute
alain suguenot ça aurait pu en 1983 l
époque on avait un slogan rejeté jeu de
président du rpr dans la nièvre à
l'époque de françois 8h et de pierre
bérégovoy et à l'époque quand on disait
la reconquête commence par les villes
quand on regarde le calendrier avec bel
évidemment l'année prochaine fier c'est
l'intérieur septembre on est à peu près
dans le même scénario donc c'est vrai
qu'il y a aujourd'hui une vague mais
cette vague elle correspond simplement
au désamour des françaises et des
français avec le gouvernement
d'aujourd'hui y compris françois
hollande
le message est très clair parrot le
message il aussi valable pour nous je
crois que ça veut dire que c'est de dire
on vous donne chaque clip en blanc
arrêté entre guillemets les difficultés
qu'on a pu connaître sur dernier les
querelles de personnes
on voit d'ailleurs que quand j'ai eu des
querelles quelque part
l'union fait la force et quand il ya une
désunion on ne gagne pas forcément et je
pense que ce message là c'est aussi un
message d'alternance je crois qu'il faut
l'entendre 5 sur 5 et je fais partie de
ce qu'ils entendent bien évidemment pour
la côte d'or
c'est vrai que c'est une déferlante
quand on regarde bien sort de dijon et
bien sûr un peu différent mais je pense
que françois rebsamen ce soir a eu très
chaud quand même parce que c'est vrai
que 52 et quelques c'est quand même pour
un maire sortant qui au surplus je les
ai toujours dit un jour mon franc parler
qui n'est pas n'importe qui je crois que
ils payent plein pot bien évidemment son
appartenance au parti socialiste et puis
également probablement le fait de sa
présidence de groupe au sénat
donc il ya un vote sanction y compris
contre lui et puis à bien sûr sur
l'ensemble du territoire des codeurs je
suis un président ump plutôt heureux
parce que quand on regarde bien toutes
les villes tombent les unes après les
autres y compris des villes
alors je pense à nos voisins de saône et
loire c'est un morceau de verre de bière
que je connais bien le disais tout à
l'heure le verre qu'il tombe ce soir ça
fait quand même près de quarante ans
qu'on a pas vu ça je crois que cette
sanction le parti socialiste de la
prendre en tant que tel je crois qu'il
appartient aussi pour nos couleurs de
montrer l'exemple et de se dire après
tout c'est un message qui est fort il
faut bien sûr l'entendre alain suguenot
pour l'ump le maire de beaune on va
faire réagir évidemment alain houpert
candidat ump dont pour la droite à dijon
françois rebsamen réélu ce soir alors
c'est le cas inverse de la vague bleue
elle n'a pas profité ne vous a pas
profité à dijon où l'ump ne progresse
pas finalement bon monsieur rebsamen a
été réélu et en tant que républicain je
tiens à le féliciter
je suis fier d'eux du combat que j'ai
mené souvenez-vous il ya quelques mois
mon adversaire disait que j'étais un
maire rural mais lui de gouttière ils
disaient que je n'étais pas connu et
bien je suis connue et j'ai fait oeuvre
de rassemblement d'union une droite unie
qui s'est battue qui s'est bien battue
et je pense que l'échec de monsieur
rebsamen c'est d'avoir mis le front
national au conseil municipal de dijon
et tout ça par un tripatouillage
électoral souvenez-vous le gouvernement
à changer la loi électorale en abaissant
à 10
pour cent des votants le nombre pour
être le pourcentage pourrait être au 2e
tour alors qu'avant c'était sur les
inscrits c'est totalement différent et
je pense que si nous avions eu un combat
à 2 françois rebsamen et moi je pense
que ça aurait été différent
c'est bien observer nous c'est pas votre
propre échec parce que quand même là
la droite fait un score historiquement
bas sur sur dijon et finalement on peut
penser aussi que c'est là que le fn on
en profite
l'échec c'est aussi l'abstention 41% de
qui se sont abstenus 41% qui ne sont pas
allées sont pas allés voter qui ne sont
pas allés voter pour françois rebsamen
qui ne sont pas allés voter pour les
candidats de droite
c'est un échec je pense que c'est un
échec aussi pour dijon parce que quand
le front national en ont dans une ville
ça prouve que la misère s'installe que
le chômage s'installe et c'est un échec
pour françois rabelais à l'eau père vous
avez fait le choix d'une campagne on va
dire négative qui pointait de ski de
votre point de vue était un certain
nombre de problèmes pour la ville de
chose qui n'allait pas dans le même
temps et un certain nombre d'études
d'opinion qui avaient été faites qui
montraient qu'il y avait une
satisfaction importante sur l'action de
la municipalité plus de 80% dans un
sondage qui était paru il ya il ya il ya
un mois est ce que vous regrettez la
campagne l'angle de la campagne que vous
avez fait ce que c'était la bonne
campagne offert à dijon je ne regrette
rien le combat était difficile le combat
était perdu d'avancé
il a fallu travailler sur notre énergie
notre volonté notre pugnacité
je suis installé je serai le chef de
l'opposition transrail semaines je serai
dans une opposition constructive je
serai là pour l'aider pour l'avenir de
dijon mais je serai là aussi pour
critiquer et mehdi gens savoir le droit
de dire ce qui ne va pas et j'ai dit ce
qu'il n'allait pas à dijon voilà donc je
suis pugnace tenace je suis là et nous
n'avons pas gagné cette bataille mais je
pense que il y aura une alternance dans
six ans il y aura une alternance aussi
il ya d'autres combats à mener
y'a sénatoriales directeur grosse paire
d'ailiers rédigeant vous vous en vous
handicape pour la suite et pour les
sénatoriales a vu que c'était mon devoir
d'aller à dijon
c'était mon devoir parce que l'élection
sénatoriale c'est une élection au
suffrage indirect et je ne me fais pas
de souci pour mon avenir politique
la politique c'est servir et non se
servir
je suis là pour servir la côte d'or
je me représenterai aux élections
sénatoriales et je me fais aucun souci
parce que puisque je suis un élu rural
un second monsieur rebsamen
j'ai une aura assez particulière auprès
d euros et je pense et le nombre au
nombre de messages d'élus ruraux ou
urbains
j'ai reçu ces mois derniers me
confortent dans cette position en tout
cas on a bien entendu vous serez le chef
de 6 jeudi le chef de l'opposition says
je serai le chef de l'opposition je
m'aime mais en conformité avec la loi
sur le cumul des mandats c'est à dire
c'est à dire que j'abandonne le conseil
général où là je vais le poste de numéro
deux je me mets dans les obscurs et les
100 gr de l'opposition sssa servir dijon
une remarque d'un téléspectateur qui dit
il y aura moins de conseillers
municipaux ump malgré tout non regarde
le même nom on garde exactement le
heures
vous disiez le combat était perdu
d'avancé pour tout le monde comme nous
il suffit de lire la presse l'a presque
combat était perdu d'avancé
et bien moi je suis un homme de
résilience je me bats contre la fatalité
ça ça vient de mon métier de médecin ou
on ne laisse pas les choses se faire
gilles a gagné c'était perdu lui aussi
il s'est battu il a réussi et en ligne
ont pu le départ et je félicite gilles
parce que c'est un élu de terrain un élu
qui a dit qu'un avenir et on est très
fiers que la saône-et-loire est basculée
vous regrettez que l'union était faite
tardivement à dijon et est ce que c'est
vision vous a empoisonné vous a empêché
de lancer votre campagne mais bien sûr
je le regrette
de toute façon mettons de côté le passé
moi je regarde l'avenir
nous on est là pour vous poser des
jalons j'additionne j'additionne les
différences j'additionne les gens
justement j'additionne des talents nous
avons réussi à avoir une équipe
cohérente unis mais a loupé comme pas
répondu à ma question parce que vous
avez une équipe cohérente unis mais
quand même c'est dans cette ville que
que là que la droite ne fut ne ne
progresse pas qu'est ce qui fait que ça
n'a pas pris enfin ne progresse pas
parce que nous avons front national ne
l'oublié pas oui les temps deux navires
il ya le front national il ya dix ans il
apprend à dire c'est par williams étant
n'y avait pas le front national la
droite ce confort ouaté front national
maintenant il y à un candidat de droite
voilà je suis là et je resterai là pour
vous c'est juste le front national qui
empêchait le front national l'abstention
le lot si le désamour des citoyens
vis-à-vis des politiques
on le voit il ya trois professionnels en
politique moi je suis un professionnel
de la vie gilles platret vous vous
n'avez pas été handicapées par le front
national
on a tout de même à chalon sur saône à
front national qui dépasse les 10% et il
n'y a quasiment pas fait campagne parce
qu'ils ont eu plein de difficultés pour
1 n'ayant fait aucune campagne zéro
campagne donc on est les candidates qui
venait d'ailleurs et qui n'habitent pas
chalon sur saône
c'est une vraie question parce que quand
vous additionnez à challans sur 100 de
les voir du front national tout parti
pris idéologique gardées évidemment et
celle de lutte ouvrière de deux formes
de contestation différentes
vous êtes à 15 % 15 % donc je crois qu
un opéra raison il faut qu'on
s'interroge tout ce qu'on ait gagné ou
qu'on ait perdu sur le malaise
aujourd'hui qu'ils existent nos
concitoyens vont mal la république hélas
hélas hélas besoin de retrouver un
certain nombre de repères et moi je suis
convaincu que ses repères passe
notamment par la commune par les villes
par les villages c'est par là qu'on peut
retrouver la proximité après c'est
éloignement ce fossé qui s'est creusé
entre nos concitoyens et les élus
toutes étiquettes politiques confondues
on sait très bien que la vague qui se
développe elle est liée comme en 83 et
dans d'autres exemples d'ailleurs à des
conjonctures nationales parce que le
parti au pouvoir est contestée à juste
titre d'ailleurs ce certains égards mais
le problème de fond
la montée des extrêmes qui prospère
aussi bien sous un gouvernement de
droite que le gouvernement de gauche
doit nous interpeller
donc on a besoin je pense chose le terme
de refonder la république ça les
inquiète pour les européennes mais ça ça
nous inquiète pour les européennes et
pour tous les scrutins parce que on peut
conjecturer j'espère me tromper qu'on
aura un taux d'abstention assez élevé
pour les européennes qui ne sont pas
traditionnellement un scrutin qui motive
beaucoup les électeurs et on sait très
bien que cette contestation elle
s'exprime de manière durable
donc c'est pas simplement un problème de
résultats électoraux je permets
d'insister là dessus le problème il est
un problème de société
il est un problème même de régime si
nous voulons conserver la république il
faut passer par d'autres schémas il faut
retrouver le chemin des électeurs et pas
simplement des campagnes électorales
c'est un travail de fond qui commence
moi je me suis fait élire notamment sur
des thématiques de proximité de
proximité en choisissant d'être un maire
à plein temps d'ouvrir mon bureau un
jour par semaine sans rendez vous pour
que les chalonnais puisse venir me
trouver parce qu'il y avait une demande
et on l'a bien senti donc cette demande
il faut que nous puissions la satisfaire
et ça commence par le le scrutin le plus
local qui soit cette route un municipal
nous poursuivons notre tour d'horizon
des différents départements et nous
restons d'ailleurs en saône-et-loire
partout pour le bio france 3 bourgogne
du creusot andré billardon nous en nous
attend et nous entend aussi bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous quatrième mandat
pour vous mais au deuxième tour cette
fois andré billardon c'était plus dur
cette campagne par rapport aux
précédentes a beaucoup plus dur en effet
les résultats du second tour pas tout à
fait serré puisque l'écart entre mon
adversaire et moi-même et de quatre
points il n'en reste pas moins que
la situation a nécessité naturellement
une campagne extrêmement active entre
les deux tours dès lors d'ailleurs que
que mon adversaire proférées à la fois
mensonge approximations parfois insultes
et quand j'entends évoqué les
différences entre la droite républicaine
et l'extrême droite
je note que dans un certain nombre
d'endroits les méthodes de la droite ne
sont pas très éloignées de celles de
l'extrême droite est à cela le creusot
n'était pas habitué nous avons dû faire
face est celui qui ambitionnait d'être
le maire du creusot
au bout du compte a échoué mais ça
nécessitait de notre part une campagne
extrêmement active et très militante
dans les derniers jours andré billardon
question d'erick sicot oui et donc vous
avez été mis en ballottage quand même
pour la première fois vous pour vous
est-ce que c'est quand même dû à
quelques phénomènes locaux ou est ce que
c'est vraiment la vague bleue et tout
cet effet là qui vous a mis en
difficulté mais c'est d'abord pour une
raison simple lorsque il ya deux listes
il n'y a pas de deuxième tour et dans
l'histoire du creusot il n'y avait
jamais eu de liste aux élections
municipales
donc il n'y avait jamais eu par
nécessité et par droit de deux tours
cette fois ci quatre listes au premier
tour
le ballottage m'a été imposée par la
dispersion des voix et pas par le fait
de la droite plutôt par la dispersion
extrême gauche et écologistes et au
deuxième tour je me suis employé à
assembler pas autant que je leur ai
souhaité pas autant de leur ai souhaité
et au bout du compte néanmoins avec une
étiquette socialiste qui n'est pas la
plus porteuse il faut bien dire les
choses comme elles sont
dans la période actuelle nous l'avons
emporté et vous qu'il était
ministre est ce que vous appelez vous
aussi à une réaction forte de paris mais
de toutes façons de toute façon nous ne
pouvons pas en rester là et par
conséquent il faudra bien tirer les les
conséquences d'une situation qui est
évidemment difficile pour la majorité en
place
de mon point de vue je n'ai pas
l'intention de remettre en cause les
orientations qui sont prises aujourd'hui
au plan national
j'ajoute que je n'ai pas je n'ai plus
été depuis un certain nombre d'années de
responsabilité nationale concentrant
toute mon action sur le creusot et la
proximité
il reste que je crois profondément que
sur des enjeux de méthode
c'est à dire de volonté de d'expliquer
d'abord de mettre en oeuvre ensuite dans
des lits dans des délais brefs les
décisions qui sont prises
cela appelle je crois un certain nombre
de décisions lourdes qui sont
aujourd'hui entre les mains du président
de la république et donc j'appelle de
mes voeux une reprise en main forte de
l'action nationale car il en va
naturellement des deux de l'avenir de ce
pays
merci andré billardon direct de france 3
bourgogne au creusot nous allons revenir
sur la situation de sens à présent dans
l'yonne où marie louise fort et telus
après avoir affirmé date de 2001 à 2008
elle revient aux affaires à la ville de
sens vous le voyez avec un peu plus de
51% ce soir devant la son étiquette
francine weecksteen retour sur cette
soirée à 100 ça c'est un reportage de
sylvain billau et jean-françois guilmard
en famille ni la tête de liste ump udf
attend la proclamation des résultats
marie louise fort et souriante à la
proche du désormais qu maire sortant
michel fourré
calais 1173 avec plus de 51% des
suffrages maric du sport ne cache pas sa
joie de retrouver le fauteuil de maire à
distance ainsi francine weecksteen de 18
points soit 1500 boix vives censée
laisser donner l aventure commence avec
eux et avec leur soutien mercialys
non je serai jamais pronostics les gens
mais shirt la candidate sans étiquette
front to back stand n'a donc pas pu
inverser la tendance du premier tour
elle arrive seconde avec 2674 de voix 33
% c'est pas mal sûr sur une ville sans
étiquette politique pour les gens de
droite j'étais à gauche pour les gens de
gauche j'étais à droite c'est quand même
bien de savoir qui à 2700 personnes qui
nous ont fait confiance au bon sens 2014
avec une participation équivalente au
premier tour soit 51 % le fn reste
stable à 15,7 pour cent mais entend
peser sur les débats au conseil
municipal
ce sera une opposition conforme à ce que
nous voulons c'est à dire une ville qui
soit plus performante plus sécurisé et
d'huile et où il fasse bon vivre et donc
le front national sera là pour rappeler
que certes il ya une majorité mais
surtout il y aura une opposition une
obligation qui sera très ferme très
vigilante
le conseil municipal devrait se réunir
durant le week-end pour élire le maire
le conseil compte désormais 27
conseillers ump ud6 sans étiquette et
deux pour le front national
22h40 dans cette spéciale municipal
deuxième tour sur france 3 bourgogne et
nous partons pour nevers où nous attend
le candidat du front national christophe
gaillard bonsoir vous avez obtenu à près
de 11% premier tour 8,2 au deuxième tour
ça veut dire que le vote sanction peut
être du premier tour ne s'est pas
confirmée au 2ème tour à nevers oui
bonsoir non il ya eu simplement un
report de nos voix qui se sont dispersés
donc sur la liste de denis thuriau pour
battre le parti socialiste ce n'est pas
une nouveauté je crois que c'est un
élément assez général c'est global en
france pour trouver un peu partout dans
les plus grandes villes de france donc
nous avons subi le même sort également à
nevers mais nous nous maintenons et je
crois que c'est très heureux et nous
apprécions d'être présent maintenant au
conseil municipal de nevers
nous serons ici présents à nevers pour
défendre les noeuds vers soi et défendre
toutes les thématiques que nous avions
évoqué lors de notre campagne
l'insécurité
le social l'économie et l'immigration
bien évidemment nous nous serons
évidemment au conseil municipal pour
nous battre dans l'opposition une
opposition que nous voulons constructif
bien entendu denis therriault en tête ça
vous surprend costa ce gaillard
non ça ne me surprend absolument pas
puisque vous savez quand on fait le
grand écart on quitte le parti
socialiste six mois avant les élections
et qu on se fabrique une éthique en toc
avec l'étonnant de l'ump de l'udps et y
ait une colistière que nous avions
également du front national je pense
qu'effectivement il aurait peut-être
même pu recevoir recueillir 90 % des
suffrages dans ce contexte
merci christophe gaillard pour le front
national en direct de nevers et nous
allons rester justement dans la nièvre
avec sylvain mathieu pour évoquer la
situation globalement dans la nièvre
sylvain mathieu nouveau à nous retrouver
voilà c'est sylvain mature réactions
enregistrées de sylvain mathieu donc
pour évoquer la situation globalement
dans la nièvre en écoute au premier tour
on a parlé d'une claque pour le ps ce
soit au niveau local au niveau national
je crois que ce soir me parler de
véritable tremblement de terre puisque
la nièvre
est une terre historiquement très ancré
à gauche donc effectivement c'est un
revers pour toute la famille socialiste
mais au delà pour toute la gauche
nivernaise alors moi je crois qu'en
politique il ya deux qualités
essentielles à avoir c'est de la
lucidité du courage je crois que ce soir
une fois on redouble et lucidité pour
comprendre les causes de ce qui nous
arrive
car en politique je crois qu'il n'y a
guère de hasard et que généralement on
récolte ce que l'on sème
par conséquent à nous d'étudier à chacun
s'ils concernent mais aussi
collectivement quelles sont les causes
qui nous ont amenés à ses déboires
électoraux
il ya une autre qualité c'est le courage
donc le courage d'affronter la réalité
en face
les raisons bon on l'est on les connaît
une élection locale est toujours
difficile pour le parti ou la famille
politique qui est au gouvernement
ça s'est jamais démenti nous-mêmes
pendant dix ans nous avons gagné toutes
les élections locales alors que la
droite gouvernemnt donc un retour de
balancier qui gérait qui est
relativement normale est pas surprenant
mais ça ne suffit pas à tout expliquer à
mon avis il ya une autre cause également
au niveau national qui est une déception
des électeurs de françois hollande on
l'entend beaucoup en fait je considère
que ce soir ce n'est pas tant une
victoire de la droite que cave entre une
défaite de la gauche la gauche
socialistes nivernais l'on veut un peu à
ce gouvernement rejeté aujourd'hui on ne
voit pas par les citoyens à travers ces
élections municipales oui je le pense je
me rends je l'entends des camarades qui
sont plutôt à l'ailé gauche du ps le
le disent depuis ne disait pas au début
je pensais m'en dans les six premiers
mois à voir la première année de
gouvernement bon c'était normal qu'ils
aient des ajustements mais la patience
comme on ne se fait de se faire poindre
y compris jusque dans leurs rangs donc
il faut l'entendre
donc moi j'appelle de tous mes voeux
tous nos responsables nationaux alors
nos parlementaires
nos responsables à solférino
naturellement mais aussi tous nos
camarades qui sont pour vous recommande
au gouvernement et à notre président de
s'interroger et de réorienter leur
politique sylvain mathieu pour le parti
socialiste dans la nièvre on rase tout
le parti socialiste et lilian melet
question je vous hais le média fait vous
faire rebondir sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre 6 bat mathieu vous faites
partie de ceux qui pensent que voilà il
faut remanier il faut changer de
politique il faut est-ce que les gens
vous l'ont dit ça sur le terrain quand
vous avez fait cette campagne
d'ailleurs une manière pas excessive
dont ils sont restés sur des enjeux
locaux sur les questions de proximité
qui les concernent au quotidien donc
bien sûr on en a eu
on a eu quelques remarques bien sûr ici
ou là évidemment mais je crois que il
faut rien attendre d'un remaniement si
les seuls
il faudra aussi une politique plus
cohérente plus réactive elle expliqué
l'expliqué donc aux français
donc au quotidien se servir des relais
locaux pour cela donc moi je crois qu'il
faut il ya un travail
il ya un travail à mener en proximité
donc sur tous ces sujets là je crois
qu'il faut il faut réagir
il faut vraiment réagir vous l'attendez
du le début de semaine cette réaction
à écouter dès que possible mais encore
une fois il faut regarder les choses sur
le fond le fond des choses
nous attendons donc une réaction
importante importante dans les
politiques a amené donc nous nous le
faisons sur le terrain je crois donc
depuis des mois des années donc
notamment alors à longvic puisque nous
faisons tous les jours sur toutes les
questions qui concernent les habitants
donc j'attends de la même manière que le
gouvernement prenne en compte cette
attente
intéressons nous à présent au cas de
nouveau en saône et loire la ville avait
basculé à gauche en 2008 la droite la
reprend ce soir vous allez le voir avec
frédéric le bush et qui arrivent en tête
monique bonin obtient 26% la maire
sortant de louhans reportage al
hand stéphanie des pierres et if and
cipher pour une première candidature à
une élection c'est une réussite
frédéric bouchet l'emportent avec 45 7%
des voix
cet agent immobilier sera le prochain
maire de louhans je tiens à remercier
déjà tous les électeurs qui nous ont
fait confiance et puis qui ont bien
voulu nous porter la plus haute marche
mais je tiens aussi à dire à tous ceux
qui ont choisi un autre candidat que à
partir de ce jour louhans-châteaurenaud
va retrouver cette unité qu'elle
n'aurait jamais dû quitter
donc le rassemblement de
louhans-châteaurenaud est parti en
deuxième position marie françoise muller
avec 28 2% des voix l'ancien socialiste
était candidate dissidente
elle devance de 70 voix la maire
sortante la socialiste monique bonin qui
ne décolère pas selon elle si la droite
a repris mans c'est la faute de marie
françoise muller elle dénonce un travail
de sa de la compétition politique à ce
niveau là quand on a une personne
dissidente dans son équipe
voilà il a passé son temps n'ont pas
travaillé au service de la collectivité
au service des administrés mais à
contrer l'équipe en place et je trouve
que c'est un beau gâchis
les deux femmes se détestent après une
campagne délétère les résultats de ce
soir mettre un point final à la rupture
marie françoise muller savoure sa
deuxième place tout à fait honorable
et puis je pense que il faut maintenant
tourner la page je félicite frais de
bouche et pour son score je lui c'est à
lui et son équipe bonne chance
l'élection du nouveau maire de louhans
doit avoir lieu vendredi soir sur cette
situation alors en riant il ya donc on
n'a pas prononcé celui de rémi chaintron
président du conseil général de saône et
loire c'est lui qui avait pris la ville
à la droite dans une situation
particulière on va dire dans la vague
pour le coup de 2008 parce que loin une
ville qui a voté à droite aux élections
nationales
il était sur la liste de monique bonin
derrière mais la ville est vraiment
perdu et il est forcément il est
forcément dans cette affaire avec le
fait qu'il ya une guerre personnelle
avec ma réponse entre le parti
socialiste et et marie françoise muller
qui dure depuis longtemps il nous
l'avait dit jérôme durain en début de
semaine c'était irréconciliables le parc
le ps savait depuis le début que que ça
allait est impossible et là ils perdent
avec un volume de voix qui est supérieur
au nouveau maire et nous restons saône
et loire avec quelques gnons à présent
nous partons pour notre bureau de mâcon
où nous attend le maire réélu dominique
lotte bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
en direct réélu ce soir donc avec un peu
plus de 51 % des voix il avait une autre
liste de gauche avec vous dans cette
triangulaire pour cette élection 2014
oui bonsoir votre réaction à cette terre
élections et goûter il ya d'abord
beaucoup de satisfaction pour l'équipe
qui est autour de moi avec une
réélection à roda de ce que l'on pouvait
espérer parce que dans une triangulaire
finalement c'est compliqué toujours dans
ce genre de situation finalement la
liste que j'emmène qui est une liste
parti socialiste mais également quelque
peu ouverte
et bien finalement nous faisons
résultat qui va à peu près identique à
celui de 2008
question de lignan melet dominique lotte
bonsoir on sait que gueugnon c'est une
base électorale importante pour la
gauche
est-ce que vous dans cette campagne vous
confirmer ce qu'on a entendu par un
certain nombre de candidats c'est-à-dire
l'idée d'une sanction ou est ce que vous
faites partie de ceux qui disent mais
finalement nous le disait pas pendant la
campagne nous n'avons pas ressenti cet
élément de politique nationale sur le
plan local nous avons fait une campagne
qui étaient dirigés en direction de la
population locale ce contrat d'avenir
que j'avais proposée d'ailleurs aux
gagnants des réunionnais a obtenu la
majorité donc sensiblement accepté
validé par la population et dans le même
temps on sent bien tout autour de nous
que finalement le contexte national a
pesé
on vous prête l'intention de vous
présenter aux élections sénatoriales est
ce que vous confirmez ou ou non à
écouter aujourd'hui je crois qu'il est
un petit peu tôt pour envisager ce genre
d'hypothèse je crois qu'il faut faire
l'analyse des résultats sur le plan
local sur le plan départemental aucune
porte ne se ferme mais cela manquerait à
la fois d'élégance par rapport à la
population locale qui m'a fait confiance
donc je me retournerai 1 vers elle mais
aussi d'amitiés et de manque d'élégance
vis-à-vis de mes camarades et de celles
et ceux que j'ai accompagné soutenu
pendant de très nombreuses années et je
me garderai bien de toute annonce ce
soir parce que j'ai une pensée toute
particulière pour celles et ceux qui
malgré le bon travail qui a été réalisé
par elles et eux se retrouvent dans une
situation avoir perdu leur mandat et
c'est bien évidemment d'abord à elle est
à eux que je pense ce soit dans une
situation très complexe
alors qu'ils n'ont pas démérité alors
qu'ils auraient pu l'emporter au regard
du bilan qui a été le leur sur le plan
local je me garderai bien de toute
annonce merci dominique lotte règles et
donc maire de gueugnon ce soir des
résultats avec vous il a besoin
oui on commence par la côte d'or et la
ville
de quetigny il avait raté la réélection
de deux voix au premier tour michel
bachelard socialiste est réélu cette
fois ci avec 55% des suffrages l'ump
totalise 35 % des voix je à chevigny
saint sauveur malgré sa mise en examen
michel roger ump est élu avec 51 % des
suffrages devant le socialiste louis
legrand 31% et le divers droite jean
perd 1 16% à auxonne raoul langlois
avait même père et lui pour son deuxième
mandat il devance de 13 points la liste
d'union de jacques françois quoiqu'il
saint jean de losne il avait ratp le
fauteuil de maire au premier tour michel
de l'ugtg sans étiquette remporté la
mairie avec 53% des suffrages
et puis au gros plan sur
plombières-lès-dijon jean-françois cour
des loges le sortant jean paul hesse le
candidat divers droite est élu avec 56 %
des suffrages
merci à lilian melet plombières les
dijon n'en avait parlé dans du premier
tour c'est une très forte division de la
gauche entre le maire et son premier
adjoint qui ne se sont pas
incompatibilité
voilà encore une avec une
incompatibilité de personnes et puis il
faut qu'on parle d'auxonne dont on n'a
pas encore parlé ce soir ville très
particulière où il ya toujours eu des
équilibres politiques alors très
complexe il y avait eu un regroupement
des listes de la liste de mener par une
tête de liste de gauche qui s'est alliée
contre le maire sortant avec une liste
de droite une troisième liste d'ailleurs
était derrière même si elle n'était pas
dessus le total des voix de ces listes
auraient dû donner la victoire à la
nouvelle liste fusionnée
ça n'a pas été le cas à raoul langlois
résister il avait déjà résisté lors des
élections précédentes il est attaqué
très régulièrement et il s'en est encore
sorti cette fois le pronostic était pas
forcément extrêmement favorable avant
avant cette élection les trois autres
listes avait fait 60 % contre 40 pour
lui jamais on a besoin des mathématiques
on ne fait pas de la politique avec une
calculette il faut le dit que j'avais
envie de faire réagir gilles platret
parce que on vous a vu réagir pendant
loin louhans c'est pas loin de chalon
c'est votre zone va dire de votre zone
de connaissances et d' influence oui
louons c'est une très belle victoire
même si un contexte vous l'avez dit de
deux divisions pense que la vraie c est
un objectif intéressant pour 2017
je pense concrètement que dans le cadre
de l' échelle je vous parle pas de moi
un joueur mais non je vous l'aurais dit
avoir je vous l'aurais dit avant mais je
pense simplement que ce territoire qui
est aujourd'hui aux mains d'une députée
un peu sectaire un peu trop sectaire peu
sinon à venir
bien sûr c'est elle peut revenir demain
dans un giron un peu apaisées et c'est
vraiment je crois le travail qui va
devoir être celui du maire de louhans
c'est de sortir de ses sempiternelles
querelles et de servir l'intérêt général
dans un climat apaisé mais je lui fais
confiance
une autre commune que vous connaissez
bien c'est tournus oui tournus et bien
sûr j aimerais un journaliste il ya
quelques années
là c'est un terreau est intéressante
puisque c'est le regroupement de
plusieurs listes finalement qui crée la
victoire c'est une ville qui a des
formidables atouts d'ailleurs je
souhaite vraiment à pouvoir rencontrer
mon futur homologues de tournus très
rapidement je pense que nous avons un
axe a créé le long de la saône de chalon
jusqu'à mâcon et jean patrick courtois
quelque chose de formidable à faire en
matière de valorisation de la bourgogne
du sud en particulier
donc ça ça va je pense incontestablement
facilité notre tâche images commentaires
réactions images à dijon
de la soirée électorale françois
rebsamen est donc réélu pour un
troisième mandat ce soir réactions et
images avec christophe taris et romain
nivôse il est 21h 45 quand françois
rebsamen arrive pour annoncer sa
réélection devant ses sympathisants
le maire soulager proclame les résultats
et sa victoire avec près de 53 % des
voix
il est reconduit pour un troisième
mandat sans vrai suspense la fin d'une
campagne mais difficile que prévu
poursuivre leur action
j'ai pour que dijon reste même si ça
déplaît à certains
le deuxième tour n'aura pas plus
mobilisé les électeurs près de 40%
d'abstentions la droite et allahou père
voulait les convaincre il réalise l'un
des moins bons scores sur la ville la
bataille était trop dure et un contexte
déjeuner qui est particulier bon je
regrette effectivement le score c'était
décevant cdc dément pas ce que j'ai fait
en 2008 aussi un j'oublie pan j'oublie
pas ma défaite
je n'oublie pas aussi les enseignements
qu'on a pu en tirer derrière dijon
s'endort ce soir avec un maire réélu et
peut-être bientôt à ministre dans ses
discours françois rebsamen à critiquer
les technocrates parisiens et leur
absence de social le remaniement est
bien déjà dans les têtes
je me pose aussi des questions je
l'avais dit pendant la campagne
je ne demande rien je peux vivre sans
être je verrai si j'ai des propositions
qui me sont adressées tel n'est pas le
cas pour l'instant
fin du débat en tout cas jusqu'à demain
alain houpert vous interrogez vous aussi
sur l'avenir dijonnais de françois
rebsamen
enfin je pense que si on lui propose un
poste de ministre il va accepter
donc il a vu un double langage
une semaine il disait qu'il restait
dijon la semaine suivante il disait
qu'il souhaitait être ministre dans ce
reportage
il a été dit que c'était une victoire
qui a été difficile quand même un cas
était difficile qui était peut-être
annoncé mais qui a été difficile et je
suis fier de ce combat ce combat que
j'ai mené c'est un combat qui était
difficile mais je suis fier du chemin
le résultat n'est pas là et le chemin
était merveilleux des rencontres les
dijonnais de belles rencontres de beaux
échanges et puis un espoir en 1010
jaunet savez c'est la première fois que
monsieur rebsamen et mis en ballottage
alors je n'accepte pas ce genre de
comment dire ce genre de paroles en
disant que j'avais un score moins
important
qu'en 2008 déjà en 2008 je n'étais pas
là je suis un homme neuf et gémit
monsieur rebsamen en ballottage le
chiffre ses volumes de voix françois
xavier dugourd au premier tour de 2008
17700 voix pour vous 13 1294 au premier
tour avec une abstention record et c'est
le chiffre le volume de voix le plus
faible pour la droite a dit jean d'un
premier tour d'élections municipales
objectivement ce chiffre n'est pas
contestable mettons les chiffres en
fonction des inscrits oui et pourcentage
en fonction des inscrits là c'est autre
vent avant c'est autre chose
la présence de françois xavier dugourd
elle et il a souhaité ne pas se
présenter à cette élection
en même temps on le voit là ils étaient
ils étaient dans la campagne est ce que
c'était gênant pour vous est-ce que
c'était une aide puisqu'il était on va
dire le leader de l'opposition pendant
tout le mandat à dijon il a passé le
relais
il l'a bien passé françois xavier est un
ami c'est quelqu'un qui a encore un
avenir en politique un qui va du bien
sûr qu'a décidé de ne pas se présenter
aux élections municipales
donc il m'a demandé de prendre le relais
c'est ce que j'ai fait c'est pas facile
c'est un combat difficile de se battre à
dijon mais il ya encore six ans et je
pense que en 2001 dijon va basculer
on s'est dit on peut dire que c'est le
statu quo sur l'agglomération dijonnaise
ce soit voilà donc pour ce qu'on pouvait
dire ça et ses résultats au 2e tour des
élections municipales je rappelle que
vous retrouvez l'intégralité sur notre
site bourgogne point france 3 point fr
via twitter vous commentez également
tout au long de la soirée on se retrouve
demain pour deux rendez vous importants
midi pile pour le 12 13 et puis à 12h55
nous reviendrons avec nos invités
également sur ses résultats du deuxième
tour pour l'instant la soirée municipale
continue avec carole gaessler et francis
letellier très bonne soirée à tous